I would rather look different and be
awesome than just fit in the mold and
never stand out you haven't lost chances
to like be successful
anytime you're just putting in work
you're gonna get better over a period of
time lead motivation what's that believe
nation is evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's lessons from a woman who went
from learning gymnastics swimming and
dance growing up to becoming an elite
CrossFit athlete making a guest
appearance in the blockbuster Wonder
Woman movie and being an entrepreneur
with her own apparel and protein line
she's Brooke ence and here's my take on
her top 10 rules a success enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one just do it I don't have to give
power not only I do not have to give
power to my negative thoughts I don't
have to give power to strangers thoughts
like people say dumb stuff all the time
and if you don't like the way I look or
you don't like the way I dress it still
doesn't affect the fact that I'm still
gonna go and be successful and I'm still
gonna go and be the person that I'm
supposed to be even if you don't like me
what advice to give to people who focus
on other people's words all the time how
do they move past that and not let it
affect them I think it's just I
recommend just it's a practice it's
literally a practice and I've one thing
I've started to do especially on like
social media or even if it's maybe I'm
out in the streets and someone has
something mean to say I will smile like
and I've been working with you who just
ensue eyes mmm
so Justin sua is a sports psychologist
and he works a lot of MLB players and
he's been working with me and something
like he was really helping me prepare
for the regional because I was already
like weeks leading up like an emotional
like a roller coaster like I think that
I hadn't quite yet felt things or let
myself feel things that sorry I've like
touched my mic a million times let
myself feel things that were a natural
response to what I had been through and
I was starting to feel them like I would
be completely fine and then all of a
sudden I was like I could I could just
like start crying my body I felt anxiety
in my body like not just in my my heart
or my solar my head it was like
physically in my legs and my arms and
something he talked about was like every
time you know if I have a worry or a
stress or maybe I have like a negative
thought about my own performance or
something come into my head it's like it
just like smile at it and I couldn't let
it go and I do that and I do it
physically I think about it I
I remind myself that it doesn't it
really doesn't matter and we have
thoughts all day we have thoughts all
the time and one of the best things
someone told me one day as he said you
know think of it it's like like okay the
birds would they say birds that fly over
your head we have no control over them
but what we can control if is if we let
them build a nest in our hair so it's
like we might have these thoughts so
people might say some things but we can
just let them go mm-hmm and if we you
know pay attention to them or give them
power and that's when it's just gonna
start like stirring and she's gonna
create problems and so I definitely am
practicing it all the time yeah you know
and practicing celebrating myself a
little bit more I'm not super great at
receiving compliments huh or talking
about myself for the matter and I think
that's also stuff that I dealt with like
what the impostor syndrome type thing
like I knew I know that I'm doing a lot
of really amazing things and and having
great opportunity and it's not because
it's just like because I'm a fluke and
people are like for a second thing I'm
you know qualified it's because I am
doing things it's because I am good at
business it's because I am good with
people because I I do work hard for my
goals I do want to help people I do love
making people happy you know I love
building businesses and working with
teams of people that want to be
successful and make changes and
differences that's all real and so I'm
getting a lot better at not only letting
things go that will only cause grief
even though that grief won't make a
difference and what if I wake up and get
out of bed tomorrow I might like that
you that's the thing - it's like
realizing well is that it's not gonna
change what you do like tomorrow are you
still gonna get up usually getting out
of bed I'm sure gonna go to work so
realize that if you you have you haven't
lost chances to be a better person you
haven't lost chances
to love yourself you haven't lost
chances to like be successful because we
have all these moments where you
literally can just just do it just be
the person that you want to be just
smile with the people that they walk
down the street because you want to be a
happy person you know it's just you just
get to do it rule number two be prepared
for new opportunities power and beauty
is an aspect of grace I've decided for
myself and for the way that I look I
would rather look different and be
awesome
then just fit in the molds and never
stand out I'm an athlete I'm an athlete
full time I like being an athlete I want
to be an athlete that has lots of you
know I've got a big tool kit and I want
to be in movies and do more acting and
I've been doing acting classes I did
musical theater till I was in college I
like it but I'm not like that's not my
career this is my career and that's just
something cool that I'm could be really
good at that I'll add to it so I am
preparing myself because I know some
opportunities are gonna arise and I want
to be more prepared for them rule number
three have a Champions mindset I think a
lot of people want to hear from a rookie
I'm just going there to have a good
I'm gonna go there and have fun hell
yeah I'm gonna go there and have fun but
I'm going there to podium
I have always been more of an explosive
athlete and love powered clean deloused
wok clean my gym nasties have gotten so
good this year and that have worked all
year to be consistent
[Music]
expect to be surprised
[Music]
started doing Crossfit 2009 so when
there was a chance to start competing in
2010 I took it
[Music]
it was terrible that was literally of my
first time given in CrossFit and at this
time I was a full-time student full-time
dance major crosses did not take
precedence I did sectionals and Poynton
barely missed a spot
to qualify to go to regionals competed
on you crosses team in 2011 [ __ ] throw
around some weight but we took second at
Regionals and I happen to be the
alternate for the CrossFit game so I did
not get to be at the games that year
moving forward from there
trained more got better you know any
time you're just putting in work you're
gonna get better over a period of time
and that's how I went into regionals
knowing like you know whatever happens I
am better than I wasn't I started is now
I had created a drive for myself I knew
I could do it I knew I could be an
individual athlete and max wanted more
going into regionals this year I was
able to think of myself on the same
level a little bit more than I ever had
but I still thought to myself like I'm
here and I've always I never thought I
would be competing with you guys and
Here I am improved every single year
that she has gone to regionals whoops
first to the road
your current leader will kids when I
went into event seven I knew I was gonna
win it
the Rings
I learned that I'm just as capable as
anybody else and if I can keep the same
mindset that I had that anybody who I'm
behind anybody who I'm chasing they
better be scared rule number four
surround yourself with greatness
surround yourself with the people that
make that are or live or have the life
or have the happiness that you also want
mm-hmm and then just worry about what
they think or you know look to them for
opinions that's one thing that I've
learned - about people that say
something that's pretty awful or you
know have just outsider's opinions is do
they look at them do they have the life
that you want do they have the job that
you're working towards do they have the
happiness that you want if they don't
then ignore them because they're not
even on the same plane as you they're
here and your trajectory is here so you
know be true to yourself and surround
yourself with like-minded people that
make you better rule number five live
life your way I'm not very religious
anymore you were I mean I grew up Mormon
when I was in high school and I had a
teacher tell me that if a boy asked me
to a dance and if he was not going to
church every Sunday I should say no
because that boy would never be able to
take me to the temple I was like huh no
not going to do that I grew up where we
give respect to all people and I grew up
your parents raised you like that yes
and I have a family that my own family
doesn't go to church every Sunday so I
wouldn't choose someone else over them
right you know it was just there was a
lot of things that would happen and I
just chose to ignore this that I thought
was dumb and and live in practice the
things that I loved I think
of things are taught through shame and
guilt the religion absolutely you know
and I got to a point where I was just
that crosses over into all parts of your
life not just your religion learning
that or having that be a way of teaching
someone anything and from when you're
very young that will stay with you
forever so I was always a very guilty
person over the dumbest stuff I got some
funny stories actually can't tell why I
mean I probably tell one now but like I
could not I mean I held I had so much
guilt and every time I went to church
and my dad wasn't there people would ask
me where's your dad you know I would or
if I was if I went boating with my
family on a Sunday and I go to church
the next vehicle where were you
how'd you get that sunburn oh you're at
the lake on Sunday yeah with my family
you know there's just there's so many
people in religion that they just
they'll just keep more guilt more shame
more guilt more shame and you can't help
but that be something that you might
experience other things throughout life
where someone else doesn't have to make
you feel guilty or feel shame you'll do
it to yourself and you're just holding
yourself back when in reality I would
rather focus on living further now
versus constantly making decisions based
on what might happen when I die and
that's where things changed for me rule
number six commit fully unless you fully
commit yourself for anything you'll
never reach your potential
want to do physically anything it takes
some consistency and you've got to
remember that it's just it's it takes
time you can't have it today you can't
necessarily have it tomorrow and if it's
with training remember that that's gonna
keep you safe it's gonna keep you
healthy and take it one day at a time
rule number seven maintain a neutral
mindset how's your head better than it
better than it was I think that no I
don't think that I know that I'm gonna
be there's gonna be quite the emotional
roller coaster I think I've been feeling
that though if I get past couple of
weeks the best thing I'm working on now
that I can do to handle it is um allow
myself to feel all the emotions that I
feel whether I'm upset I'm angry or sad
or happy or you know I'm indifferent and
I don't know why or I'm anxious and feel
those things without trying to suppress
them because I think that I should and
in trying to maintain a neutral life
we're all thinking against ourselves I
can't control how other people are and
honestly there's a lot of things that
are out of my control so control the
things I can and smile and laugh all the
[ __ ] that I can rule number eight
structure your life around your goals
I feel really shy after drinking because
I don't ever drink yeah you know I feel
like you make decisions you cut things
out your diet and put them in based on
one what your goal is and two what are
your non-negotiable is like what makes
you happy right like a non-negotiable
having like a beer on the weekend cuz
that's what you like in the social
aspects awesome like cool that and nuts
and there's nothing wrong with that I
think when you start looking at
something because you're making maybe
your new goal is like something's wrong
with your health right now it's like
okay well now what is the most important
it is that more important than a beer
well yeah well then I can get rid of the
beer it's always should be like what's
my goal and then what are the things
they also happiness is very important to
you know like I after realizing it so
many times I'm just a happier person I
feel better if I'm not hungover rule
number nine focus on the little moments
I don't try to look too far in advance
because I get overwhelmed really you
know like if someone has a lot of weight
to lose if their goal is like lose a
hundred pounds I can only imagine like
even with me with some of my goals like
this recovery it feels like it's so far
away and it takes so long for you to
like start seeing a difference that like
you're naturally are motivated to keep
going right
did it be super easy to give up or to
want to stop but if you and I tell
people is if you just focus on all those
little moments along the way
to ignore what your big goal is time
goes by so fast
yeah like a year goes by so unbelievably
fast that it will be here before you
know it and I completely agree that
sometimes if you focus on something that
is so far away or does feel so out of
reach you can definitely get too
discouraged like before you actually try
to get there and rule number ten the
last time before a very special bonus
clip is have fun hey guys thank you very
much for helping me get to 1 million
followers on Instagram I am so grateful
for all of you and I feel like this is
what I deserve
[Music]
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Brooke on how to make a change that
I think you're really gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions I want you
to make sure you're moving from not just
watching another video but into action
in your life or your business so answer
these three questions on your own at
home talk about them with the friends or
leave the answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what do
you need to just go out and do question
number two what does living life your
way look like and question number three
how can you better structure your life
around your goals thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
winter regionals fought like hell call
I'm going into the final event there
were six of us in contention for the
final spot for the games
I had to beat two of the girls I beat
one of them and the other girl I need to
beat one the last event from what I
understand I was one point away from
qualifying and all the trolls just came
rolling in on social media holy cow and
they weren't just attacking my
appearance anymore they were attacking
like my character you know my drive my
work ethic my like all these things that
was really hard for me to handle and
think about and then also I always had
some thoughts you know or insecurities
or questions about like myself
internally I never had told people and
so what happened is like when you don't
tell people and it's just in your own
head you're thinking oh yeah I was
probably not real like I'm thinking it's
all real if I wanted to be better if I
wanted to be better than I ever could
have been I needed to work through this
stuff like I needed to tear the walls
down I think to a certain point the
walls I had built or the things I had
the lies I had told myself so I could
like get through a day without thinking
negative thoughts but myself probably
really helped me get to a certain point
but you become anything more or better
bigger than that I had to deal with them
and that's kind of what happened
how'd you deal with them well I read a
book one talking to people that are
really trusted you know the thoughts
that I have instead of just keeping them
inside because I'm embarrassed about
them saying them out loud to someone
that I trust it's a naked one when you
tell them to a friend and they look here
like you know it really goes that yeah
but then also too sometimes you say them
out loud to yourself and you're like oh
that sounds way dumb like you realize
that what how ridiculous is yeah so a
lot more of that and then I read a book
from brené Brown daring greatly yeah
which is correct literally promote a
book to like everything
yeah and that was probably the book that
really helped me decide how I could
sort of mending things moving forward
and realizing that we have all of these
moments that you can always just make a
change you know
like I'm feeling all these things and
I've been affected by what people have
said about me
and I knew that I wanted to feel better
and change and and move on and move
forward and grow from the experience but
for some reason it was almost like I was
waiting for this moment where it was
like well now you can write but in
reality it's like you have a million
moments yeah every moment we get to
decide and you just get to make a choice
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that move that people
need passion and not one drop of my
self-worth depends on Europe it's
supposed to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details